FAVORABLY.
DOW PLUNGED NEARLY 300.
S&P 500 DOWN 29.
NASDAQ FELL 91.
THE RUSSIA ORDERED HUMANITARIAN
PAUSE IN THE SYRIAN ONSLAUGHT
AGAINST CIVILIANS AND ONE
DAMASCUS SUBURB IS BEING CALLED
A FAILURE BY MANY ON THE GROUND.
CORRESPONDENT RICH EDSON FROM
THE STATE DEPARTMENT TALKS TO
SOMEONE RESPONSIBLE FOR TRYING
TO SAVE MANY LIVES AS POSSIBLE.
>> THIS IS SYRIA.
TWO WORDS: DOOMSDAY.
>> LEADER OF THE WHITE HELMETS,
SYRIAN VOLUNTEERS WHO RUSH
TOWARDS THE DESTRUCTION OF ASSAD
REGIME MARROW BOMBS AND CHEMICAL
WEAPONS ATTACKS.
FIRST RESPONDERS SAVING
CIVILIANS ATTACKED BY THEIR OWN
GOVERNMENT.
WITH LITTLE EQUIPMENT, AID OR
REPRIEVE FROM YEARS OF WAR.
>> VOLUNTEERS HAVE TO MAKE
CRUCIAL DECISIONS ABOUT TAKING
PEOPLE FOR -- FROM RUBBLE.
NO SAFE PLACE TO TRANSFER THE
INJURED.
>> EIGHT TRUCE WAS SUPPOSED TO
BEGIN TODAY.
IT APPEARS HE DID NOT.
>> Translator: RUSSIANS ARE
CONSIDERING SYRIAN FACILITIES
TRAINING FIELDS FOR THE JETS
THEY ARE USING.
>> THE UNITED NATIONS SECURITY
COUNCIL RECENTLY PASSED A 30 DAY
CEASE-FIRE THROUGHOUT SYRIA TO
ALLOW FOR AID DELIVERIES AND
MEDICAL EVACUATIONS.
STILL, THE FIGHTING CONTINUES.
RUSSIA BACKS THE GOVERNMENT OF
BASHAR AL-ASSAD, PROVIDING AIR
COVER.
UNITED STATES HOLD RUSSIA
RESPONSIBLE FOR WHAT IT CALLS
GOVERNMENT CHEMICAL ATTACKS ON
CIVILIANS.
>> MOSCOW PLAYS ARSONIST AND
FIREFIGHTER, FUELING TENSIONS
AMONG ALL PARTIES IN SYRIA, THE
SYRIAN REGIME, IRAN, TURKEY, AND
SYRIAN REGIME, IRAN, TURKEY, AN
AND --
>> FOX NEWS LEARNED IRAN HAS
BUILT OTHER PERMANENT MILITARY
BASE OUTSIDE DAMASCUS.
UNITED NATIONS INVESTIGATORS SAY
NORTH KOREA HAS BEEN SHIPPING
SUPPLIES TO THE SYRIAN
GOVERNMENT THAT IT COULD USE TO
PRODUCE CHEMICAL WEAPONS.
THAT'S ACCORDING TO A U.N.
REPORT "THE NEW YORK TIMES"
REVIEWED.
>> IF NORTH KOREA BECOMES MORE
DESPERATE, THEY LOOK FOR A
DIFFERENT, CREATIVE AND HORRIFIC
WAYS TO TRY TO MAKE MONEY TO
FUND THEIR CRIMINAL REGIME.
>> ANOTHER OBSTACLE FOR THE FEW
LEFT TO CARRY FOR A COUNTRY WITH
LITTLE INDICATION THIS WAR ENDS
ANYTIME SOON.
>> Translator: WHAT WE HAVE
WITNESSED, INTERNATIONAL
COMMUNITIES HELPLESS IN CRISIS.
UNITED NATIONS CAN'T DO ANYTHING
IN SYRIA.
>> IN WASHINGTON TO PUSH THE
INTERNATIONAL COMMUNITY TO HELP
STOP THE FIGHTING.
FOOD AND WATER ARE SCARCE FOR